(electronic music)
- All right, this is the pilot of Lucifer.
Act one.
Exterior, City of Angels,
Sunset Boulevard, night.
A jet black vintage sports
car sales down Sunset
cruising through the adult Disneyland
that is nighttime Los Angeles.
Neon and billboards
reflected on the windshield,
the Stones' "Gimme Shelter"
blasting from the radio, or-
- Cause we couldn't afford it.
(everyone laughing)
- Or "No Rest For The
Wicked" by Cage the Elephant.
Interior, Lucifer's car,
behind the wheel the devil himself.
Say hello to Lucifer Morningstar.
He's good-looking, a
man of wealth and taste,
but that's not what makes
him jump off the screen.
It's his vibe.
Pure lusty mischief, sardonic
smile, timeless style.
And yes, he's that
Lucifer, the son of God.
The one who rebelled,
plotted against his father
and plummeted from grace.
The one who was banished from paradise
and forced to serve as the
Lord of hell for all eternity.
Right now Lucifer's was getting
pulled over for speeding.
Motorcycle cop.
Lucifer adjust his mirror
to see Officer Diggs
approaching the car.
He yells over the music.
- Can you turn down the music, sir?
- Ah, you know what they say, officer,
if it's getting too loud,
you're getting too old.
- Do you know why I pulled you over?
- Obviously you felt the need to exercise
your limited power and punish me
for ignoring the speed limit.
It's okay, I understand.
I like to punish people too.
Or at least I used to.
- Do you have any idea
how fast you were going?
- Haven't a clue.
I blame it on the Stones,
they just make a man want to drive.
You know what I mean?
- Well, you know, sometimes
I put my siren on and
drive really, really fast,
but for no reason, you
know, just cause I can.
- Right?
And why wouldn't you?
It's fun!
It feels good to get away
with something, doesn't it?
- [Diggs] Hmm.
- (chuckling) It's okay, officer.
People like to tell me things,
those deep, dark, naughty little desires
that are really on their minds.
It's a gift.
Must be something about this face.
- License and registration.
- [Lucifer] Coming right up.
- Are you trying to bribe me, sir?
- Yes, of course.
Why is that not enough?
Here, just take more, it's only money.
- It's against the law.
- Oh you people are funny about your laws.
You break the law sometimes don't you?
Yeah, do tell.
- Well, sometimes,
I'll pull a woman over
for a minor infraction
and get it to flash me a
little something something.
- Oh you dirty dog, you.
- Sometimes I let her off
with, you know, with a warning.
Sometimes I don't.
Sometimes other stuff happens.
- Oh, LA's finest.
You're tempted to keep that, aren't you?
Yeah, so what are you
waiting for, permission?
Keep it!
Buy yourself something
pretty, you deserve it.
But if you don't mind, I
really must be on my way.
- Okay sir.
Have a good evening.
- You too, officer.
- Officer Diggs walked away,
Lucifer readjusts his mirror
but this time we see a
flash of something strange,
a glimpse of Lucifer's true reflection,
almost too fast to even comprehend,
but enough to unsettle us
or not, because we decide to
not do that later in post.
(everyone laughing)
Lucifer skims the radio and roars off
leaving one very dazed cop in his wake.
As he goes, we see the
caddies rear vanity plate
which reads "FALL1N1".
Title card.
(actors humming)
Exterior, Lux, street night.
Lucifer pulls up in front of his bar, Lux.
Doesn't look like much from the outside
but there's a long line
of Hollywood hipsters
dying to get in.
Inside Lux now a little
bit of hell on earth,
a living breathing tribute
to Lucifer's favorite things,
wine, women, and song.
Lucifer glides through
soaking up the sights
and sounds of elegant debauchery
like a proud modern day Gatsby.
His eyes land on the
exotic dark hair beauty
tending bar over yonder, Mazikeen.
But she's always been
just Maze to Lucifer.
She leans seductively with
her back against the bar,
doesn't turn around as
this for approaches,
speaks to him via a mirror.
- Where have you been?
- Holed up at the Chateau
copulating with a woman named Faith.
Ironic, isn't it?
Oh, have I ever told you
how incredibly sexy you are
when you can't control your emotions?
- And what emotions might those be?
- Why jealousy, of course.
- Try disappointment.
- A young man suddenly rises
from where he's been kneeling
in front of Maze.
Lucifer's eyebrows go up.
Didn't see that coming.
- Thank you, Patrick.
You can go.
What?
I dropped something.
Now, Lucifer I'm a big fan of sex.
- Obviously.
- But shouldn't you be
spending your valuable time
doing something more significant?
You're the Lord of hell
for crying out loud.
- I'm retired, Maze, I've
got nothing but time.
- Maze stares at him for a beat
then senses something, as does Lucifer.
A ripple in the drink she just poured.
Time slows.
Music and laughter
become warped and haunted
as everyone in the club slows
except Lucifer and Maze who share a look.
- I think you have a visitor.
(Lucifer sighing)
- And through the slow motion crowd,
Lucifer sees Amenadiel.
The man has a steady and grim intensity.
He's Lucifer's brother and an angel.
Yep, majestic wings and everything.
But Amenadiel is also a bad-ass.
Last thing he radiates
is angelic goodness.
- Amenadiel, how's it hanging big guy?
Didn't you see the sign?
No angels allowed.
No?
I'll make an exception
for you, on the house.
- You've become quite ensconced
with this little hobby of yours.
Your return to the underworld
has been requested.
- Oh!
Okay, let me check my calendar.
Yeah, here it is.
The 7th of never through to the 15th
of ain't going to happen.
How does that work for you guys?
(everyone chuckling)
See, I'm consistently
surprised by the whole
no sense of humor thing.
Look, remind dad, I quit hell
because I was sick and tired
of playing a part in his play.
I believe in free will
but not the tyranny of all
this predestination hoo hah.
- I'll warn you against
disrespecting our father, Lucifer.
- Yeah?
Well, our father has been disrespecting me
since the beginning of time.
So pot kettle, don't you think?
- You are a mockery of everything divine.
- Thank you.
But lately I've been doing
a fair amount of thinking.
Do you think I'm the devil
because I'm inherently evil
or simply because dear
old dad decided I was?
I mean isn't this a
classic case of labeling?
- What do you think happens
when the devil leaves hell?
All those demons, those tormented souls.
Where do you think they go?
- Don't know, don't care, not my problem.
Look, tell father I'm not going back.
Consider the position oficially open.
So you, my feathered
friend, are going to hell
- In a blink, Amenadiel's
wing is at Lucifer's throat.
Ancient fuel fused in its tips.
Lucifer's glass falls,
shatters, but he doesn't flinch.
- Oh, go for it.
You think father's upset now?
- Father has been patient for five years.
He will not be merciful much longer.
- Threat planted, Amenadiel
withdraws and exits.
And the club now slips
back into regular motion.
Lucifer only now deflates.
Amenadiel clearly rattles him.
Exterior Lux, street night.
Lucifer stands outside,
spinning a coin in his hand,
still thinking about his
conversation with Amenadiel,
when a taxi slows to a
stop in front of Lux.
The rear window rolls down,
a beautiful hot mess appears.
This is Delilah.
Delilah is a fallen from grace pop star,
the crowd waiting in line
reacts like crowds do
when confronted with a super
famous person, tragic or not.
Oohs and aahs and iPhones galore
but Delilah only has eyes for Lucifer.
- Remember me?
- Yes, you're famous.
Delilah, isn't it?
Could I have your autograph?
- If I can have a drink.
- Back inside Lux, Lucifer
and Delilah sit at a booth.
Maze hovers in the background.
- So why'd you really come back?
- I don't know, I guess I feel safe here.
Reminds me of who I was
before everything got so big and messy.
And for you.
Sometimes I feel like
you were the only person who
was ever really honest with me.
But I need to know something.
- What's that?
- Did I sell my soul to the devil?
- Well, that would imply the devil
is actually interested in your soul.
That's the stuff of movies and TV.
They always get it wrong.
- Come on, you took me in
off the street, Lucifer.
You let me sing up there anytime I wanted.
It's so weird.
I told you that I want it to be a star.
And that's when things
started happening for me.
And you do call yourself Lucifer.
- Call me whatever you want
but I'm really just a patron of the arts.
Look, honestly, I introduced
you to a few people
that owed me favors, that's all.
- Do you think I'm talented?
- Of course I do.
You have one of the most beautiful voices
I've ever heard.
It's sweet, dirty, sexy, soulful.
I knew you were a star, I just
helped the world catch up.
- Well, it certainly feels
very Faustian at times
because along with the good, ooh,
came a hell of a lot of bad.
- Oh, so the devil made you do it?
The alcohol, the drugs,
the topless selfies?
Your choices are on you, my dear.
- You're right, you're right.
You are absolutely right.
But the toxic relationships
were my biggest screw ups.
God, I really do have
the worst taste in men.
- You really do, darling.
Jimmy Barnes?
I can't believe you almost
married that sweaty little imp.
- He produced my album!
You introduced us.
- I suggested you work with
him, not sleep with him.
- I got confused.
- And then you left him at the altar.
- Yeah, that was pretty rude of me.
- Actually, I rather liked
that bit. (chuckling)
- He trapped me in the bathroom
at the Grammy's a month ago,
cried, said he wanted
to get back together.
Then I hear he's marrying
some supermodel this weekend
and I'm jealous!
Oh, god, I am such a mess!
- God has nothing to do with
your mess any more than I do.
You didn't sell your soul, Delilah,
but you do owe me a favor.
Looks like it's time to settle up.
- I'm scared.
- You should be.
Because what I'm about to ask
is going to be quite difficult for you.
Pull yourself together.
That's it, that's all I'm asking.
Get it together before it's too late.
You're wasting your talent, your life.
- I let you down.
- [Lucifer] Then fix it.
- Off Delilah, a glimmer
of hope in her eyes.
Exterior Lux, street
night, Lucifer and Delilah
walk out saying goodbye.
- Lucifer, I'm going to do what you asked.
I am going to get it together.
I promise.
- Without me, all these terrible things
that weren't supposed to happen?
They happened.
But what happens next is up to you.
- She nods, smiles, pulls
him in an intense hug.
They're still hugging
when a piece of shit car
slows to a stop in front of Lux.
Shots ring out.
Lucifer and Delilah are
riddled with bullets.
As they both go down in a
heap, the car screeches off.
But without warning the shooter's car
is viciously broadsided by a city bus.
A beat as everything settles.
Then an unholy groan from Lucifer
as he rises to a sitting position.
His clothes are torn with smoking holes.
He rips his shirt open,
no blood, no entry wounds.
Just pain, a lot of fucking pain.
He slowly climbs to his feet,
goes over to Delilah,
beautiful in peaceful repose
and very much dead.
Lucifer's face takes the pain.
- Very dead.
- He looks down the street,
zeroes in to the wreckage
and stalks over to it.
The shooter's body has been
thrown from the crumpled car
laid out in a pile of broken glass,
twisted and bloody, but still alive.
- What did you do?
- I'm sorry.
- Sorry?
Tell me why.
Why did you end her life?
I can smell death coming for you.
Shall I speed it along?
- Why else?
Money.
- Times like this I
wish I was back in hell.
What I would do to you.
- Hey, I just pulled the trigger.
- [Lucifer] What do you mean by that?
- The shooter coughs up a
final geyser of blood and dies.
Lucifer walks back over to Delilah,
he stands there staring down at her
with something in his eyes.
Is it loss?
Which is when we realize
we're watching Lucifer
from someone else's POV.
Exterior Lux, street.
Find Amenadiel in the shadows,
a slow motion ballet of
onlookers around him.
As he glares at Lucifer ominously,
we wonder, did this actually
make it into the pilot?
Is he observing this
moment or did he cause it?
Exterior, Lux street.
- We need Len here!
We need Len.
- (laughing) same night.
Now a full blown crime scene.
Cherry tops spin, police swarm,
coroners put Delilah's body in a bag
and into the back of their van
as an unmarked cop car pulls up.
Out hops LAPD homicide
detective Chloe Dancer.
♪ Hold me closer, Chloe Dancer ♪
- Beautiful but downplays it on purpose.
She's smart, cold, and direct.
She's strides over to the red car
where the shooter still lies
in the bed of broken glass and blood,
bends over to get a closer look,
when she hears some
snickering and whispering.
Turns to see some rookie
uniform staring at her.
- Can I help you?
- Nah, just talking about
some of our favorite movies.
- Another plain clothes detective walks up
from the other direction.
He's Daniel Espinoza, gruff, alpha dog.
(everyone laughing)
- Hey, go secure the perimeter.
- You here to babysit me?
Lieutenant said this is my case.
- Well, hi.
Nice to see you too.
Yeah, it's your case Chloe.
Want to hear what I got so far though?
- No.
- Well, it's an easy one.
(laughing) This is our
bad guy, Eddie Deakin.
Low-level drug dealer.
Found these in his pocket
and this in Delilah's purse.
So obviously drug related, right?
Maybe she owed him a bunch
of cash or something.
She wasn't exactly selling
out stadiums these days.
- But how'd you know he's low level?
- Do you see his car?
- Yeah, but look.
Look at his watch.
That ain't cheap.
- Probably a fake.
Wouldn't pick too hard at this one, Chloe.
Not after Palmetto street.
- Ah, Palmetto street!
(everyone laughing)
- Palmetto!
- Woo!
- Listen, Dan.
I begged for this case
because of Palmetto.
So any witnesses?
- Interior Lux, night,
where Chloe is now questioning Lucifer.
He's distracted.
His rolling emotions over Delilah's death
are disorienting him.
Maze hovers nearby
- Lucifer Morningstar, is that like
a stage name or something?
- God given, I'm afraid.
You look familiar, have we met?
- Yeah, five minutes ago.
And I'm asking the questions.
Talk to me about your
relationship with the victim.
- She used to work here a few years back.
I would occasionally
accompany her while she sang.
Then she became a big star
and someone decided to end her life.
- Did you know the shooter?
- [Lucifer] No, but we did
have a nice little chat.
I asked him why he did it.
- I see.
You like to play cop, do you?
- I like to play in general, Detective.
What about you?
(Dan chuckling)
- It's interesting because
the coroner's report
has the shooter killed on impact.
So you spoke to a dead guy?
- Well, he wasn't quite dead.
His soul was still crossing the threshold.
- Oh, okay then.
So why'd he do it?
- Well, money of course.
You humans love your money.
- Yes.
Yes we do.
And what planet are you from, London?
- (chuckling) He also said
"I just pulled the trigger."
Interesting, no?
- Delilah was shot to
death by a drug dealer
and looks like Delilah herself
kept the guy pretty busy.
It's sad, it's ugly, but
it's not rocket science.
I mean, something obviously
went south between them.
She gets riddled with bullets
and a nice little act
of God takes him out.
- It doesn't work like that.
Quite neatly wrapped present for the LAPD,
don't you think?
- Okay.
How does she end up dying
in a hailstorm of bullets
and you get away without a scratch?
That's very interesting, don't you think?
- [Lucifer] The benefits of immortality?
- Immortality, yes, of course.
Do you spell that with one M or two?
I always forget.
- What will your corrupt little
organization do about this?
- [Chloe] Excuse me?
- Will you find the one responsible?
Will he be punished?
Will this be a priority for you?
- You've got some balls on you, you know.
- [Lucifer] Well thank you very much,
but they're really quite average.
- I knew that.
- Are you sure that we haven't met?
I could swear I've seen you naked.
Did we have sex?
- You know what, go to hell.
- No thank you, much more fun here.
Oh wait detective, we're not done.
- Yes, we are.
- And she's out.
Off Lucifer frustrated.
We end act one.
- Meet cute, that was the meet cute.
- Yay!
I don't think those two
are ever going to hook up.
- Never.
- Act two.
Interior Lux, later that night.
Lucifer plays piano.
Fingers flying, an intense
version of Bowie's Lady Stardust.
Suddenly he smashes the keys
in a burst of atonal fury,
his gaze fixed on something ahead.
It's his reflection in
the mirrored fireplace,
that disturbing face again.
We catch just a hint of it before
he gets up at hurls a
metal skull at the mirror,
smashing it to pieces.
Maze enters, surveys
the damage, says nothing
which only serves to
infuriate Lucifer even more
and really make the audience curious.
Did we see this scene?
- (laughing) Out with it, Maze.
- I'm curious.
- [Lucifer] About?
- Why this upsets you so much.
- 'Cause there is someone out there
that deserves punishment and
it's not going to happen.
- Who cares?
Mortals die every day.
- Yes, insignificant ones.
Human nothings never add
anything to this world.
They only take and consume
and die cowardly, pathetic
deaths, but this was different.
She was different.
- You care about her.
- Please.
I care about punishing
the coward responsible.
- Who are you right now?
- I don't mind the occasional
smart ass remarks, Maze.
They can be amusing,
but don't disrespect me.
- The opposite is true.
You're the Prince of freaking darkness.
It's all well and good to take a vacation,
have fun in paradise with
all the low hanging fruit.
But you're losing sight of
who you actually are, Lucifer.
You exist to punish and
torture for a universal reason.
Certainly not for a petty
human emotion, such as love.
- (chuckling) I am not human.
Take that back.
The world was robbed of a great talent
and that makes me angry.
It makes me want to punish someone
in very unholy ways, that's all.
- Does that mean we're going home?
- He's silent.
Her smile fades, but
she kisses him sensually
then slinks off.
On Lucifer.
Maze's words echoing.
- We did shoot that scene,
but it never made it.
- We did shoot that scene.
- Deleted scenes.
Exterior, Malibu coastline.
- Too blue for Fox, that one.
(everyone laughing)
- Gliding over the beautiful ocean side.
We pick up Lucifer's Jag
as it speeds down the ribbon of highway
that is the PCH.
Exterior Malibu wedding site, day.
The wedding is in progress.
A short sweaty music
mogul named Jimmy Barnes
is about to wed a stunning
statuesque supermodel bride.
Surrounded by family and frenemies,
it's a whole big to-do.
The priest has just arrived
at the part where he says,
- Speak now or forever hold your peace.
- Yeah, excuse me!
- And Lucifer comes
strolling down that aisle.
- I have a problem.
Has anyone else noticed how incredibly
jaw-droppingly, loin-stirringly beautiful
this young woman is,
and how short, sweaty and altogether fugly
this homunculus is?
I mean, what is this, a
wedding or a kidnapping?
You know what I mean?
(everyone chuckling)
- The priest crosses himself.
- Yeah, good luck with that, Padre.
Oh, while you're at it tell him
I say hey, it's been awhile.
Jimmy Barnes!
Remember me?
- Hey man, this is a private event.
How'd you even get in here?
- Yes, quite a lavish
be it tacky one for a
record producer on the outs.
Do you remember me?
- Of course I remember you.
What do you want?
I'm a little busy.
- I can't believe you're getting married
the day after your ex-lover
and once brightest star
was murdered in cold blood.
- Yeah.
It's sad, but Delilah ruined
my wedding once before.
I wasn't about to let her do it again.
- Yes.
It was hard to be
rejected, isn't it, Jimmy?
Twice.
- What?
She said you tried.
She said you tried to
get her back recently.
I'd killed someone if they denied me once.
Not that that's possible, come on.
Come on, tell me Jimbo.
Did you want her dead?
You know I love a juicy story.
- I am not playing that
mind game with you.
Of course not.
I was furious and humiliated
when she dumped me.
But I think I rebound pretty well.
- Clearly, respect.
- You should go play
your games with 2Vile.
- 2Vile, the rapper?
- Yeah, mhmm.
Delilah dumped me for that lunatic.
A, they were always fighting.
I think he slapped her around a bunch.
He's the real deal, man.
And he's surrounded by a bunch
of gun-toting morons 24/7.
- Oh, I'm sorry, how rude of me.
Allow me to introduce myself.
- I really don't want to
have sex with him tonight.
I'm sorry, did I just say?
I didn't mean that.
- Of course you're don't.
Let's be honest here.
You're not marrying this human stain
because you're actually
in love with him, right?
- No, I guess it's more about lifestyle.
I don't know what I was thinking
- Well good luck with that, he's broke.
Dry your tears, darling.
At least you'll have this magical day.
Well, I should be going.
Best of luck to you crazy kids.
- Lucifer turns and
walks off down the aisle,
a figurative mushroom cloud in his wake.
(actors laughing)
Exterior 2Vile's place,
Hollywood Hills, day.
Lucifer cruises at the
drive of a pimped out palace
that could easily have its
own very special episode
of MTV cribs.
Lucifer exits his car, rings the bell,
a massive gong sounds.
Door's opened by a white English butler.
- Good afternoon, sir.
- I'm here to see the
man sadly known as 2Vile.
Is he in?
- I'm sorry, sir.
He's unavailable.
I'm afraid he's in the mourning.
- I have narcotics for him.
- Right this way, sir.
- Okay.
- Inside 2Vile's place moments later,
Lucifer follows the Butler into the den,
furniture from MoMA.
2Vile's crews are scattered
all over the place.
Hip-hop's thumping.
There's tons of weed,
weapons, it's a real scene.
An immensely expensive
plasma TV in the background
plays news on Delilah's death.
The hot headline.
- Can someone please turn
down this God awful music?
- Who's this clown?
- Oh, he has narcotics for you, sir.
- The name is Lucifer Morningstar.
- Lucifer Morningstar?
That's a good hip hop name.
- That offends me.
- What do you,
what, you don't like hip hop?
- No, I most certainly do not.
- Well that offends me.
You have a problem with black people?
- Not in the slightest.
I just hate your music.
When I say your music, I mean your music.
Not music made by other black people.
Without the blues, there'll be
no devil's music whatsoever.
There are of course many
giants in the field.
Just not you.
Am I being clear?
- You're being clear, all right,
If you're looking to get yourself killed.
- Don't waste your
munitions, I'm immortal.
Tell me about Delilah.
- What's to tell?
Bitch is dead.
- That ignites Lucifer.
He violently shoves 2Vile,
sending him shattering
through a glass door,
toppling over the
balcony to certain death.
Just as Lucifer grabs him
by his blinged out chains,
suspending him high above the hillside.
- No, no, no, no, don't shoot him.
Don't shoot him, you idiot.
I didn't kill her!
- Why should I believe you?
- Because I loved her.
- People sometimes kill people
with whom they're in love.
The heart is mysterious or so I'm told.
- Girl made me crazy, okay.
- Well women can do that.
Doesn't mean you should beat her up.
- Hey, hey, hey, come on.
We worked that out a long time ago.
I hit her once.
'Cause she was cheating on me.
- Huh.
With whom?
- I don't know.
She wouldn't tell me,
said it was a big secret.
Some rich married guy.
- Well did she have a friend
she might've confided in?
- Didn't trust no one.
Her therapist is probably
the only one who knows.
Some doc.
(tune playing)
Sorry about that.
Some Dr. Linda in Beverly Hills.
- That's Dr. Linda's music.
- Yeah.
Saw her like five times a week on the DL.
Used a fake name and everything.
- Thank you for your time. (sighing)
- Man, sometimes I get
tired of fronting, you know?
I really just wanted to
put a ring on that finger
and a baby up in there.
(everyone chuckling)
Wow, she was the one.
Now she's dead.
- You know, I like the side of you.
You might consider putting
this kind of emotion
into your music.
And change your name.
What does your mother call you?
- Percy.
Percy Wallace.
- Yeah, nevermind.
Good luck with what's left
of your short lived career.
- Lucifer starts to leave when,
- Guns down, on the floor!
- Detective!
Welcome to the party.
- Guns down.
You, grab that bucket.
Pick them up now.
- Oh, you sly dog.
You did listen to me.
- Ran the dead guy's cell phone.
2Vile was the last person he called.
Oh, come on, man!
- Oh, sorry!
- What I find highly interesting
is how you made the
connection on your own.
- Well I've been busy, my dear.
- Talk to me about Delilah.
- Yes, yes, we've been
over that one, detective.
- And why you called the shooter two days
before she was murdered.
- Fine, yeah, yeah.
I called Eddie cause he
hooks me up sometimes.
He met Delilah through me.
When we were together, whatever.
Don't don't make me a killer, do it?
- No, but it does make you a suspect.
- What, so everyone on
Eddie's phone is a suspect?
You joking?
Welcome to the celebrity name game.
You're going to drag half
of Hollywood downtown?
Be like the Oscars.
- Chloe reaches for her cuffs.
Meanwhile, the celebrity moment
has triggered recognition
in one of 2Vile's crew.
- Dennis, you're muted.
- I knew that was gonna happen.
Wait, wait, wait.
Aren't you that chick from the film?
- What's this, what film?
- Yeah you used to be
that actress or something.
Right?
I mean that teen movie.
I forget what it's called.
- Of course!
Hot Tub High School, that's
where I know you from!
- Let's stick to my questions
shall we, thank you.
- The one with the famous nude
scene coming out the hot tub.
It was a complete Fast Times ripoff.
You were like the new Phoebe Cates.
Oh, that was quite a nude scene.
- I've got way too many bullets in here
for you still to be talking.
Come on, you're under arrest.
- That's a waste of time, detective.
I've just threatened his life.
He's not our guy.
He would have said, trust me.
- What, you did what?
- Yeah, isn't that illegal?
- A little bit, yeah.
Okay, you don't go anywhere.
You come with me.
- Oh, with pleasure.
Do these go any tighter, Detective?
- Chloe slaps the cuffs on Lucifer
and a smug smile doesn't leave his lips
as Chloe yanks him out.
Exterior 2Vile's place.
You know, we think it'd be really fun
if we just did a little thing right here.
Lucifer and Chloe,
why don't you switch?
Or Tom and Lauren, switch roles?
- Yes.
- Oh yes.
- Just switch roles?
Okay.
- Are you ready?
- Yeah.
- In unit?
- Okay.
All right.
At least perhaps you'll listen to me
although not sure I understand
why I'm being arrested.
- 'Cause you're interfering
with a police investigation?
You've broken I can't
even count how many laws
and you piss me off.
- Don't like that.
- I can get out of these, you know.
- Funny.
What, how did you do that?
You a magician or something?
- You're still wasting time.
We should be out there solving a homicide
and punishing those responsible!
- We?
Are you insane?
Get in the car, I'm taking you in.
- But that's boring,
not to mention pointless.
Come on, it'll be fun!
- How could you possibly help me?
- Mm-mm, you'd be surprised detective.
I have a certain skillset, mmm.
I can be very persuasive with people,
I tend to see things others can not.
- So you're a psychic.
- No, no, I can't read people's minds.
I'm not a Jedi.
People tell me things.
- Really, just confess their sins?
Just like that?
- No.
Not their sins, I have no
power over people's sins,
I actually get a bad rap to that.
But their desires, mm,
different thing entirely.
I have the ability to draw out
people's forbidden desires,
tempt them, taunt them.
The more simple, more
human, the easier it is.
The more complex, the more
challenging and exciting really.
But your actual sins, the
sins are on you people.
- Are you in Bridgerton?
(everyone laughing)
- Season two, season two!
- You people.
I get it, the name, the
whole Lucifer thing.
And what, desire is like your super power?
- More like a gift from God.
Look, I'm just a people person.
They feel compelled to
share things with me.
And why wouldn't they really?
I'm pretty awesome.
- Yeah? Prove it.
- That I'm awesome?
Isn't it obvious?
Tell me detective,
what do you desire more than
anything else in this life?
- When I was a little girl
I always wanted to be a cop like my daddy
so that one day I could help
people make a difference
and make them shut up
and get in the damn car.
- You're not like a Jedi
or something are you?
- Get in the car.
- Wait, I know something you don't know.
- [Chloe] Yeah, what's that?
- Won't say unless you
take me with you on this.
Please, come on.
I got to 2Vile, didn't I?
- You're unbelievable.
Huh.
You don't strike me as
a celebrity stalker.
You weren't sleeping with her, were you?
- Surprisingly, no.
- Then why do you care about
this so much, about Delilah?
- [Lucifer] I just do
- Fine,
But if you're a little
clue doesn't pan out.
I'm putting these back on
and you're going to stay on.
And they're going to stay on.
- Lucifer cracks a smile, nods.
She gets in the car and follows,
both of them growing more and
more intrigued with the other.
And we should have always
had you guys swapped.
That was amazing.
- Yeah, so good.
- End of act two.
- I don't like this guy.
He sounds like Michael
and I don't like him.
(everyone laughing)
- He went Michael on Michael.
- Full Michael.
Never go full Michael.
- Sorry.
- Act three.
Interior Chloe's police car, driving, day.
Lucifer's in the backseat.
Chloe drives on the phone.
- Yeah, therapist in Beverly Hills
with the first name Linda.
See if, um, Delilah was a client please.
- Actually, she had a pseudonym,
which I also happen to know.
Quite good at this, aren't I?
Penny Lane.
- Delilah could have gone by a Penny Lane.
Okay, thanks.
What, don't be so smug,
hasn't panned out yet.
- No, that's not it.
I knew I recognized you.
- Right, right, you saw my boobs.
Good for you.
Never heard that one before.
- Yeah, and your ass, don't forget.
A thing of beauty.
- I will pull this fucking car
over right now and shoot you.
- I told you I'm immortal.
(sighing) Is the movie why you have
such a chip on your shoulder?
- Trust me, that's low on the list
of things that I have to live down.
- Yes, attractive female cop
struggling to be taken seriously
in a man's man's world, that it?
- Something like that.
- Well, who cares what the other pigs say?
You're a kick-ass detective.
Should listen to me a bit more maybe,
but you know who you are.
- I know who I am.
There's just a lot of people out there
who have a problem with it.
Other cops, mostly.
- Well they're threatened.
You're clearly smart and
have notable instincts.
Ignore them, trust yourself.
- Chloe's cell goes off.
- Did I say Decker, right, Dancer.
Anyhow, we changed it.
Detective Decker, right?
I knew that. (laughing)
Only said my own name for six years, okay.
Detective Decker, really?
Okay, yeah.
Text it to me, thank you.
- [Lucifer] What?
- Looks like what you said holds up.
There's a Penny Lane
who sees a Dr. Linda Martin,
address is in Beverly Hills.
- Excellent, I'll clear my schedule.
- Another call interrupts.
- Yes, what?
You're kidding me.
Is she okay?
Her father was supposed
to pick her up today.
Yeah, he should be there already.
Of course he's not, okay.
I'll be there as soon as I can.
So listen, we have to make a pit stop.
- What, no, absolutely not.
- I have to get my kid from school.
She got into a fight.
- Well can't she get herself home?
- No, she's seven.
- I'm not here to help you run errands,
I'm here to help you solve a homicide.
- Chloe just hits the gas,
pinning him to the backseat.
Exterior elementary school street, day.
Chloe pulls up in front.
- Wait here.
- With pleasure.
I despise children.
- Going frowns, gets
out, locks the car doors
and heads into the school.
Lucifer stares at the car lock, it pops.
And then he gets out to stretch,
goes to light a cigarette when
a MILFy mom crosses his path
and disappears into the school.
Lucifer likes what he sees,
decides to follow her in.
Interior elementary school, day,
Lucifer looks around
but the MILFy woman has disappeared.
Lucifer frowns, sits down in the lobby,
gets ready to light a cigarette again
when a precocious little
thing named Beatrice
pipes up next to him.
- I don't think you're
allowed to smoke in here.
- Oh dear.
What will become of me?
- My mother's a police officer.
She could arrest you.
- Oh, I think I might know your mother.
We're working together
on a case, top secret.
- You know my mother?
- Unfortunately yes.
- What's your name?
- Lucifer.
- Like the devil?
- Exactly.
- Well my name is Beatrice.
But everyone calls me Trixie.
- That's a hooker's name.
- What's a hooker?
- Ask your mother.
Why are you in trouble?
- That girl over there.
- The ugly one?
- Yes.
Damn, look what you just did.
Yes.
She's bullying me.
She made a fake Snapchat account
and use it to make fun of me.
So I kicked her in the no-no touch zone.
- The no-no touch zo-oh
I see, well played.
- He gets up, walks over to the mean girl
and sits beside her.
- Hello, mean girl.
Did you know that you will never amount
to anything in this life
and that there's a special section of hell
reserved for bullies?
So have fun.
- Lucifer's eyes peel open
revealing a flash of
horrid ones underneath.
Mean girl burst into tears.
As she does she suddenly slows.
In fact, everything around her slows.
Lucifer's grin fades.
We know that this means,
Amenadiel is near,
apparently in this draft.
Lucifer stands, looks out in
the far end of the hallway.
Children pass in surreal motion.
- Story of my fucking life.
(everyone laughing)
- We shot this too.
- When suddenly a distorted voice
calls out to Lucifer from behind.
He turns.
- Hello!
What did you do?
- Oh, I think someone is
feeling a little guilty.
Isn't that right, child?
- More tears from meanie,
a smile from Trixie.
Off Chloe WTF.
Exterior elementary school, street, day.
Lucifer, Chloe and Trixie walk
out as Dan Espinoza arrives.
What's he doing here?
- Hi, Daddy.
- Wow, shocker, you're late.
- Give me a break,
I'm putting the case to bed.
- (laughing) Right?
Like I'm not working a case too?
You remember the one you
tried to steal from me?
- Oh, you mean the open and shut one?
You did open and shut it, right?
- Have you been going rogue, dear?
Exciting.
- I'm not going, oh, that's not me.
- I'm not going rogue,
I'm just being diligent.
I need to get this right, Dan.
It's a very high profile case.
- Exactly.
Which is why you need
to be smart about it.
- She is smart.
You're a dimwit.
But perhaps you should refrain
from arguing in front of the child.
It's unbecoming, not to mention
another waste of my time
which is far more important to me.
- Who is this douche?
A new boyfriend?
I thought we agreed not to...
- Please allow me to introduce myself.
I'm a man of wealth and taste.
I could make you see things
that would drive you blind
or pull your spine out
through your ass, your choice.
But I wouldn't do any of these
things in front of the child.
And you know why?
Because I, for one have excellent manners.
- I don't know whether
to laugh or shoot you.
- Oh, surprise me.
- Isn't he funny, daddy?
- Hey, can you drop Trix at my mother's?
Thanks, I got to go. Give
me a kiss, Trix, all right,
mommy loves you so much.
And good job standing
up to that mean girl.
- Oh, thanks mommy.
What's a hooker?
- Daddy will tell you.
- Bye, Lucifer.
Nice to meet you.
- Mmm.
- I think she likes you.
- Of course she does.
What's not to like?
- Chloe follows after Lucifer.
This man is be-fucking-wildering.
End of act three.
Act four, interior therapist's
office, waiting room, day.
Lucifer and Chloe wait.
- [Lucifer] (sighing)
So was your offspring
planned or a mistake?
- [Chloe] Excuse me?
Planned, sort of.
- Hmm, explain to me the
human desire to procreate.
I've never understood it.
Children are hideous little creatures,
terrible taxing burdens.
I mean, your kid's fine.
I mean, nothing to cry about
but nothing to be too
embarrassed about either.
- Are you at all aware
of how dickish you sound?
- Speaking of case.
Why was that dum dum you were married to
pressuring you to close the case?
- No reason.
- [Lucifer] Strange.
- Yes, you are.
- No, I'm still not affecting you.
- Well, actually you're
making me nauseous.
- Hmm, did my father send you?
- Dr. Linda Martin pokes her head out.
- Okay Detective, I'll see you now.
- Interior therapist's office.
Lucifer and Chloe sit
opposite the therapist,
Dr. Linda Martin, very
uptight and very put together.
- Okay, so I'd like to ask you
a few questions about Delilah.
- You're thinking about it, aren't you?
- [Linda] What?
- It's not a good idea.
I'm like walking heroin.
Very habit forming, never ends well.
- I'm sorry, do you two know each other?
- No, but I know that look.
- I don't know what you're talking about.
- It's interesting because
you don't look at me that way.
- What way?
- Well, with carnal fascination.
- That's because it doesn't exist.
- No, you see that's just it.
With most women, it does.
I tend to appeal to the
dark mischievous heart
within all of you.
But you, Detective,
you seem oddly immune to my charms.
- Referring to them as charms
is a bit of a stretch, I think.
Truth be told, I find you repulsive
like on a chemical level.
Seriously, you're gross.
I mean, you flat out give
me the heebie-jeebies.
- Fascinating.
- You say it's fascinating,
but I see it disturbs you, doesn't it?
Deeply.
- Dr. Martin, we know Delilah was having
a clandestine affair with
a wealthy married man.
Just tell us his name and
we will be on our way.
- I'm sorry, I can't do that.
- She's one of the complex ones.
Watch and learn.
Linda, darling, tell me.
- No, I can't. (giggling)
I want to, you know, but I can't.
You're the devil!
- (chuckling) Correct.
Now tell me, Dr. Martin,
'cause I know you want to.
- Oh, darn!
And it's really juicy too!
- Did you roofie her?
This is unbelievable.
- That's not her fault.
She's just reacting to me.
Watch and learn.
The answer is yes, Linda.
We can take a trip to
pound town if we must
but you have to tell us.
- Mmmm (chuckling) okay!
It's Grey Cooper.
- What?!
Grey Cooper?
That is pretty juicy.
- The actor?
The one married to Amanda what's her face?
Oh he's horrible.
So square jawed and handsome, so vanilla.
Quite disappointed in Delilah.
Truly terrible taste in the opposite sex.
- Thank you, Doctor.
We will definitely be in touch.
Lucifer, let's go.
- Of course, but I made a deal.
I need to hold up my end of the bargain.
- What, you're not actually talking
about having sex with
her right now, are you?
- I do a lot of yoga.
Hot yoga.
I'm freakishly flexible.
See?
Wow, really tried to keep that in.
- You tried, that's what matters.
I do apologize, but I'm going
to have to take a rain check.
I will be back.
- I certainly hope so.
- My word is my bond.
- Chloe's shaking her head.
She's beyond stymied.
Following Lucifer out.
Exterior, downtown industrial area.
Lucifer walks with purpose
down a dingy street
pushing his way past a group of onlookers
crowded behind a barrier.
As he starts to pass,
a feeble traffic cop tries to stop him.
- Sir?
Sir, you have to stay
behind the barricade.
- Lucifer ignores him, stepping
casually past the barricade
when suddenly a muscle car
comes speeding around the corner
pursued by two police cars.
Lights, sirens and gunfire.
Muscle car's tire blows
and the car flips and crash
slides right toward Lucifer
who doesn't move as it skids
to a halt inches from him,
when we hear,
- Who the fuck is this guy?
- Oh, he's with me, sorry.
- But you're not Grey Cooper.
- No, of course not.
What the hell is this?
- We need to speak with Grey Cooper.
- Exterior downtown street,
different area moments later.
Lucifer and Chloe now
with the real Grey Cooper,
same cuts and bruises as a stunt guy
and the uniform stand nearby.
- Oh, Delilah, yeah.
I heard about that this morning.
Can't believe it.
We did a movie together last year.
Got pretty close.
- Lovers?
- Friends.
- Friends who were lovers.
- Settle down.
I'll handle the questions, thank you.
Mr. Cooper, when did you last
have contact with Delilah?
- Sorry, I just have one more question
before we proceed with the boring ones.
Mr. Cooper, what do you
want more than anything?
What is it?
What's your deepest, darkest desire?
When you close your eyes, what do you see?
- I'm the president of the United States.
- Hah!
Who's the devil now?
- Those are some pretty big
aspirations there, Mr. Cooper.
- Well, after the acting and stuff.
- Oh, don't be embarrassed.
Hell if Arnold can do it, right?
But you wouldn't want any nasty secrets
screwing that up for you, would you?
- No, no, no, I wouldn't.
- Better to pull the skeletons out now,
the public's very forgetful.
- More importantly, why would
you want to be a politician?
I mean, you get to make movies,
isn't that much more fun?
Not that I like yours much.
- Is there a point to this?
- Mr. Cooper, were you having
an affair with Delilah?
- Honey, have you been getting my texts?
I thought you were breaking for lunch
like half an hour ago.
What's going on?
- Well, these people are detectives.
- Real ones?
- Yes, ma'am.
Well, you know, I am.
- It's really quite striking in person.
Luminous actually.
- Thank you.
- Interesting, I've never
been very fond of you
on the big screen.
- Thank you?
- I'm sorry.
Lucifer Morningstar.
- Oh, wow, great name.
What is this all about?
- Oh we have some questions about Delilah.
- Oh, yes.
That's so sad.
- Yes, very sad.
- (laughing) Your watch,
where'd you get it?
- It's a prop.
- No, that's the one
Delilah gave you, isn't it?
For "Time Will Tell"?
- Oh, right.
That's the movie we did.
It was a wrap gift.
- She gave a $10,000
watch to the whole crew?
- Oh no, just me.
As far as I know.
We were, you know, costars and everything.
- You'll have to lie better than that
if you want to be president,
(coughing) excuse me.
- I know, right?
- So you were sleeping with her then.
- Oh yeah.
- I can hear you.
- So can I.
- I just said that out loud, didn't I?
- Uh huh.
- In front of people.
Police people.
Whatever, not like I didn't know.
And Grey, you're a terrible
liar and actor by the way.
- You knew?
- Of course!
Why do you think I've
been sleeping with Bobby?
- (gasping) Are you serious?
- Oh yeah.
And let me tell you, it's good.
I climb that man like a tree.
(woman laughing)
- My bodyguard?
What a cliche.
- Oh, okay.
I'm a cliche.
Well you're a dick.
(everyone laughing)
- Arrest them.
One of them's gotta be guilty.
- Well, that was fun.
- Everybody fights.
And now,
(everyone laughing)
- I read somebody's part, I'm so sorry.
- Now Chloe can't help
but crack the slightest
smug smile at this time.
And they watch the
chaos they both created.
Exterior Lux, street, night.
A vigil honoring Delilah on the sidewalk,
candles and letters
around a small TV playing
one of Delilah's performances.
Now we're inside Lux, night.
Chloe's got a beer in one
hand, cell in the other.
Smug smile gone.
Lucifer sips his scotch,
spinning that coin.
Maze stands a few yards away
watching disapprovingly.
- I know, I know, check again.
What about their
assistants' phones, nannies,
fan pages, Twitter?
Okay.
Well, call if anything changes.
Grey and Amanda have zero connection
to the shooter or the driver.
Maybe Dan was right.
Maybe the shooter wasn't
working for anyone.
Maybe this does start and end with him.
- No, I don't believe it.
- He did have the same damn watch as Grey.
Can't be a coincidence.
Maybe Delilah gave it to him too,
kind of her go-to gift.
- Well, that would imply she
was sleeping with that maggot.
- Let's see, Jimmy, 2Vile, Grey Cooper.
She was sleeping with three other maggots.
Not like she has tremendous discretion.
God, why am I here?
- Wrong deity, but that is the
eternal question, isn't it?
- No, I mean here, in a bar with you.
- Well I don't know, Detective.
Despite your proclaimed revulsion,
you can't deny there's
a connection between us.
Tell me, what do you really want?
- You mean, what do I desire more
than anything else in this life?
- Hmm, yes.
No tricks.
Not that they work with
you anyway, you freak.
Just tell me, I'm curious.
- I suppose what I was saying
before, you know, to you
was kind of true.
I do want to help people.
- Ugh, your purity repulses me.
- Well, your lack of it isn't
wildly attractive either.
My father was a cop, pretty great one.
My mother was an actress,
pretty cheesy one.
And she tried to kill me in a scene
with a glass, just kidding.
I tried the acting thing.
I took my top off.
Not exactly contributing to
the betterment of society.
- Disagree.
- Anyway.
Didn't like how it made
me feel about myself.
So I quit.
I became a cop like my old man,
dealt with the whole Hot
Tub High School thing
till I became a detective
and found a whole new
way to ostracize myself.
- Ah, the reason your ex-maggot
was pressuring you to close this.
- Yeah.
A few months ago, I saw a case differently
than a lot of people in my
department including my ex.
I stuck my neck out.
It backfired.
Now it seems like most of them hate me
and nobody wants to work with me.
- Chloe shakes her head,
but can't help but smile.
Maze interrupts to grab the glasses
when a familiar music clip plays.
- Too bad your little protege's not around
to cash the check.
- [Chloe] Wow.
- [Lucifer] What?
- Delilah didn't get that watch to Eddie.
- Interior recording
studio later that night.
Late night session, a
young boy band recording.
Tired mixers at work
and Jimmy harping on a Justin Biebery kid.
Door booms open, techs and mixers curse,
as Lucifer and Chloe interrupt the session
making a beeline for Jimmy.
- Hello Jimmy, how are
the album sales doing?
- Ready, Tom?
- Oh, yes please, hit me.
- I believe Whitney
Houston reached the top 10
for album sales after her death.
Michael Jackson hit the stratosphere.
Having Delilah killed,
you're bound to reach at least the top 20.
That's a truckload of royalty
checks coming your way.
Guess you need that cash, huh?
Which is why you had to pay
the shooter with your watch.
- The watch Delilah gave you.
Now that's just sick
but then you are so...
- Jimmy's sweaty face turns red.
He grabs one of the boy bands as a shield
and whips out a fucking gun!
Chloe's gun is out in a blink.
- Whoa!
Whoa, whoa, hey Jimmy.
- I made her!
And she ruined me!
She humiliated me!
She owes me!
- You're not God, Jimmy.
You didn't make her.
But you did destroy her
so I'm going to punish you.
- Back off, you freak!
I mean it!
I'm not going to prison for that bitch.
No fucking chance!
- Oh shit.
- Listen to him.
Back off.
- It's fine, I told you I'm immortal.
- Jimmy's twitchy.
Lucifer gets too close and
Jimmy's swings his gun up
to fire on Lucifer and boom!
Chloe gets off two shots first.
One hits a lamp, the other nails Jimmy.
He drops to the ground dead.
And here's the fun part.
Lucifer's pissed.
- Why did you do that?
- He was going to kill you.
- No, no, no, you just
let him off too easy.
He needs to suffer, he needs to pay,
he needs to feel the pain, not escape it.
- Well, I mean, don't worry.
I'm sure where he's going,
the punishment's coming. -
- Actually, no it's not.
And why?
Because I'm here, and he-
- Boom, boom, boom!
All eyes were off Jimmy
who was still ticking
and fires off three shots of Chloe.
One lands.
Chloe goes down.
- No!
- Chloe staggers, blood coming up fast.
Lucifer hurries to her side.
- I don't want to die.
- I won't let you.
My father will just have to wait for you.
- The moment is interrupted
by more shots from Jimmy.
Lucifer protects Chloe now
using his own body as a shield.
- Jimmy is crazy.
(everyone laughing)
- That's right, motherfuckers!
- Wait here just a second.
- Lucifer turns and we stay in Chloe's POV
her vision blurred, distorted.
She's catching only glimpses
but sees Lucifer walk over,
grab Jimmy by the neck
and slam him up against
the nearby glass booth.
The glass cracks in a spider web
and we see Lucifer's broken demonic face
in the shattered glass behind Jimmy.
- Please don't kill me.
- You're gonna wish that
was all I did to you.
- And then Chloe's vision is lost to black
and we hear Jimmy's blood curdling scream.
Over that moment of darkness
which then gives away to
a bright tunnel of light.
Oh wait, it's just regular light.
A hospital bed light.
Interior hospital room, day.
Chloe is coming to.
We find Lucifer hovering over her.
- Well, look who's back.
- How long have I been out?
- Three years.
(everyone laughing)
- You're such an ass.
He was firing at you.
Why are you not more dead?
- You're having a very hard time
with the whole immortal thing, aren't you?
- I must have been delirious
from the blood loss.
- Well, whatever helps you sleep, my dear.
- What happened to Jimmy?
- He got what he deserved.
- Well, I am pretty sure I'd be dead
if you hadn't have helped me.
So, thank you.
- Sorry, I missed that last part.
- Thank you!
- You're welcome.
Besides, you're far too
interesting to let die.
- You saved my life because
you find me interesting?
- Wildly irritating as well, but yes.
- So now what?
- Well, obviously I've proved myself
as an invaluable crime fighting tool.
You were a pariah in the department.
I think this is the beginning
of a beautiful friendship, don't you?
- Who the hell are you?
- I told you.
I'm-
- Lucifer!
- [Joe] It's Trixie,
ex-husband Dan in tow.
- Oh, now now.
That's enough, child.
Save some of this
unpleasantness for your mother.
I think she's one hell
of a homicide detective, don't you?
- Uh yeah, she is.
I'm happy for you.
- Yeah, thanks.
- I'm trying to compliment you here.
- Okay.
I will take it.
Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- I bet the department's
surfing. (laughing)
Dan, are you okay?
- I'm being a douche,
that's my version of a douche.
- I love it.
- It feels like Kevin's here, so.
- Yeah it's just like Kevin actually.
Spot on.
- Uncanny.
Where were we?
- Top of 37.
- Yeah, but you need to be more careful.
You should've had backup.
- She had backup.
- Thank you,
for helping her.
- (sighing) It's hard for you, isn't it?
Not to be a douche.
Well I'd stay for the family reunion,
but it's given me terrible IBS.
Look forward to seeing you soon, Chloe.
- I don't.
- Bye now.
Glad you're not dead.
- Yeah.
- Lucifer leaves but
looks back for a moment,
curious as to why he gives a good god damn
about any of them.
He frowns, troubled.
Exterior Lux, street, night.
Lucifer pulls up, gets out,
handing his keys to the valet
who greets him with a smile
and says nothing
because he has just
slipped into slow motion.
- Ugh, bloody hell.
What do you want from me?
- I've been watching you, Lucifer.
- Perv.
- I'm not sure that I like what I see.
You've been showing restraint, mercy.
- I'm scared I'm turning
away from the dark side, bro.
Going to give you a little
competition for dad's fave?
Don't worry, I'm not.
- Oh, I don't believe you.
The human world can be even
more painful than hell, Lucifer.
Stay here and prepare to feel things
you have never felt before.
- Don't threaten me, Amenadiel.
You won't win.
- Then go back.
- You're the one who's threatened.
- Oh, Luci.
My hatred of you grow
stronger with every visit.
- Wouldn't have it any other way, pal.
Look forward to eating your heart one day.
Peace.
- Amenadiel turns and walks off.
Lucifer watches him go.
These two brothers will never, ever,
ever be close.
Interior (everyone laughing)
Interior Lux, moments later.
That was my narrating, by the way.
Lucifer drops down at the piano.
Maze watces from a short distance.
What looks like a dagger
spins on its point
in the palm of her hand.
But before we get a
good luck, she stops it,
walks over to Lucifer quiet.
- Hints of disapproval, Maze, what is it?
- I just can understand why
you would save a human life.
- There's something different about her.
Something I can't figure
out and it vexes me.
- Maybe it's not her that's different.
- Is this where I ask
whatever do you mean?
- Stop caring.
You're the devil.
- Yes.
Yes, I am.
- But there's doubt in his eyes
as he launches into an
eerie instrumental rendition
of "Gimme Shelter", which continues over
into your therapist's
office, waiting room, day.
Dr. Linda Martin sits in her office
as she notices a little red
light blinking over a door.
She's confused.
Doesn't have an appointment right now.
She gets up, opens the door.
Linda startles cause Lucifer's
standing right there.
- Here's the deal.
We can have as much naked
cuddle time as you desire
but I need you to listen to me too.
I have a few things I'd
like to discuss with you.
An existential dilemma or two.
Deal?
- Linda smiles, deal.
And as the door shuts behind,
we smash to black
and Van Halen's "Running
With The Devil" kicks in.
On a show that,
I don't know, the devil solving crimes.
- I know, never gonna work.
- I don't see it
lasting a season.
- Will it get picked up?
Will it get picked up?
- End of pilot!
(clapping)
- It's got three years tops.
(actors laughing)
- You guys, that was awesome!
And it is so nice to
see all of your faces.
- Nice!
- Mwah, mwah, mwah.
- Bye, guys.
- Hi, bye.
- Thanks for watching, guys.
- Thanks, everybody.
- We love you, take care.
- Love you guys, bye.
- Bye.
- Bye, everybody.
(electronic music)